So last time we saw this,
we saw an example of a mixed strategy,
which was to play a third,
a third,
a third in our rock,
paper,
scissors game.
All right.
And today we're going to be formal.
We're going to define mixed strategies and we're going to talk about them and
it's gonna take a while.
All right,
so let's start with a formal definition
definition,
a mixed strategy and develop notation.
As I'm going along,
just let me call it piece.
I buy,
I being the person who's playing it.
Piece I buy is a randomization.
Randomization
over eyes,
pure strategists.
Okay.
All right,
so in particular we're going to use the dictation piece of pie of SSI to be the
probability that player I plays Sii given that he's mixing using Pi.
All right?
So pis PSI is the probe in the sea
that Pii assigns to the pure strategy
s I and it's immediately refer that back to our example.
So for example,
if I'm playing third,
a third,
a third in rock,
paper,
scissors,
then Pii is a third,
a third,
a third and Pi of a rock that would pee.
Ai of Ar is a third.
All right?
So without belaboring it,
that's all I'm doing here is developing some of the station.
All right?
It's immediately counter.
Two things do you might have questions about,
so the first is that in principle pis,
cy could be zero.
Okay?
All right?
So just cause I'm playing a mixed strategy,
it doesn't mean I have to involve all of my strategies.
All right?
I can pick and mix strategy on two of my strategies and leave the other one with
zero properly.
Prevalency so for example,
again in rock,
paper,
scissors,
we could can think of the strategy are half a half zero,
right?
And this strategy I assign,
I play rock half the time I play paper half the time,
but I never placed scissors.
All right.
[inaudible] to understand that.
And while we're here,
it took at the other extreme,
the prevalency he assigned by men by mixed strategy to a particular,
SSI could be one.
It could be that I assign all the privacy to a particular strategy.
What would we call mixed strategy?
That eScience problem.
Was he one to one of the PR strategies?
What's a good name for that?
That's a fuel strategy,
right?
That's a pure strategy.
All right,
so now just so we can think of pure strategies as the special case of a mixed
strategy that assigns all the weight to a particular pure strategies route.
So for example,
if p I rock was one that's equivalent to saying that I'm playing,
I'm playing the pure strategy rock.
Hi,
eee up your strategy.
All right,
so there's nothing here.
I'm just being a little bit nerdy about developing notation and making sure that
everything is in place.
All right,
and just to point out again,
a one on one consequence of this is we've now got our pure strategies embedded
in our mech strategist,
right?
When I've got a mixed strategy I already am including in those,
all of the pure strategists.
All right,
so let's proceed.
I push that up a little higher.
Sorry.
All right,
so now I want to think about what are the payoffs that I get from mixed
strategies.
And again,
I'm going to go a little slowly cause it's a little tricky at first and we'll
get used to this.
Don't panic.
We'll get used to this as we go on.
And as you see them in homework assignments in class.
All right,
so let's talk about the pay offs from a mixed strategy
payoffs from mixed ranches.
Alright,
and in particular,
what we're going to worry about our expected payoffs.
So the expected,
hey off
all of the mixed strategy p,
let's be consistent and call it pie.
The mix strategy.
Pei is what?
It's the weighted average.
It's a weighted average or weighted mixture if you like.
Oh,
the expected payoffs
of each of the strategies
in the mix.
Yeah.
All right.
So this is a long way of saying something and again I think is a little bit
obvious,
but let me just say it again.
The way in which we figured out the expected payoff of a mixed strategy is we
take the aptly,
appropriately weighted of the expected payoff.
So I would get from the pure structures over which I'm mixing.
All right,
let me let,
let's abstracts,
let's immediately look at an example.
So here's an example.
We'll come back to you several times,
but just ones today.
And this is a game that you've seen before.
Here is the game battle of the sexes and which play at,
hey can choose capital play,
one can choose a capital a and B and play it too can choose little a and B.
All right.
And what I want to do is I want to figure out,
I want to figure out the payoff from particular strategies.
So suppose
p,
it's what's being played by player one and p is uh,
let's say,
um,
one fifth,
fourth,
fifth.
So what do I mean by that?
I mean the player one is a signing a fifth to playing a and for fifth to playing
B.
All right,
and suppose that cue get it.
I'm going to use p and Q because it's convenient to do so rather than calling p
one and p two.
So I suppose that cue is the mixture of that player two is choosing and she's
choosing a half half,
so she's putting it [inaudible] a half on little Aa and prophesy a half on
little B and just the Lucius.
I switched notation on you a little bit for this example to keep life easy,
I'm going to use P to B rose mixtures and queue to be columns mixtures.
Right out of the question I want to answer is what is the expected payoff in
this case of p,
what is peace expected payoff.
All
right,
and the way I'm going to do that is I'm,
first of all,
I'm going to ask what is the expected payoff of each of the pure strategies that
p that p involves over which p p is the pure strategies involved in p.
Right?
So to start off,
I just,
the first step is asked what is the expected payoff for player one of playing a
against queue
and what is the expected payoff for player one of playing B against queue?
That'll be our first question and we'll come back and construct the payoff for
Pete.
All right,
so these are things we can do.
I think so.
The expected payoff of a against queue is what?
Well,
how half the time if you play a,
you're going to find your opponent is playing little Aa,
in which case you'll get two and half the time when you play a,
you'll find her opponent is playing B,
in which case you'll get all right,
so let's just write that up.
So I'm going to get to with problems see a half plus zero with probable
probability a half.
All right.
Everyone happy with that and back?
That gives me one.
Okay.
Please correct my math unless it's very easy at the board to make mistakes,
but I think that one is right.
Okay.
Conversely,
what if I played B?
What's the expected payoff for the row player of playing B against Q or Q is a
half half.
So how for the time when I played B,
I'll meet a player to playing the lay and I'll get zero and half the time I'll
find player two is playing mental B and I'll get one.
All right,
let's write that up.
So I'll get zero half the time and I'll get one
half the time,
uh,
for an average of
a half.
All right.
Okay.
That's the first thing I ask him now to finish the job,
I now want to figure out what is the expected payoff for player one of using p
against Q.
That what the question I already wanted to start off with.
All right.
What's the way to think about this?
Well,
peers,
one fifth of the time,
P uh,
couldn't to p one fifth of the time play a one is playing a and forfirst of the
time player one is playing B.
Is that right?
So to work out the expected payoff,
what we're gonna do is we're going to take one fifth of the time.
And in which case he's playing a and he'll get the expected payoff he would have
got from playing a against Q
and forfirst of the time
he's going to be playing be,
in which case he'll get the expected payoff from playing be against cue.
All right.
And now just plugging in some numbers to that from above.
So we've got one fifth of the time he's doing the expected payoff from a against
Q.
And that's this number we worked out already.
All right,
so this number here
can come down here.
One
and four.
First of the time he's playing be against queue in which case is expected.
Payoff was a half.
Okay,
so this
comes in here.
All right,
everyone.
Okay?
So far,
how I construct it so far?
Is this podium in the way of you guys?
Are you okay?
Let me push it slightly.
Okay.
All right.
And so the total is what it's going to be.
Uh,
one fifth of one plus four fifths of a half.
A forfirst of a half is too fast.
So I've got a total of three fifths.
All right,
so the total here is three fifths.
Alright,
everyone understand how I did that?
Okay.
Now,
while it's here,
let's notice something.
When I played PE some of the time I played a and some of the time I played B.
All right,
and what did I paid it when I ended up paying,
hey,
I got A's expected payoff when I paid ba got B's expected payoff,
so the number I ended up with three fifths must lie between the payoff I would
have got from a,
which is one,
and the payoff I would have got from B,
which is a half.
Is that right?
Three fifths lies between a half.
On one hand,
we're okay with that?
Yup.
Now that's a very,
that's a simple but very general and very useful idea.
It turns out I had the idea here,
is it the payoff?
I'm going to get must lie between the expected payoffs I would have got from the
pure strategist.
Let me say it again.
In general,
when I play a mixed strategy,
the expected payoff I get is a weighted average of the expected payoffs of each
of the pure strategists in the mix.
And weighted averages always lie inside the pay offs that are involved in the
mix.
All right.
Let me try and push that simple idea a little harder.
I suppose I was going to take the average height in the class average height in
this class.
All right,
so let me just,
uh,
rather than use the class that must use some tas here.
So let me get the,
let me get these three ta is to stand up for a second.
All right.
And suppose I wanted to figure out the average height of these three TA's.
All right,
so it's not as close together is to see what's going on here.
So I think from where I'm standing,
uh,
I've got that uh,
ally as the tallest and mercy,
the smallest does that,
right?
So I don't know instantaneously what this average would be,
but I claim that any weighted average of their three heights is going to give me
a number.
That's somewhere between the smallest height height of the three,
which is matters height and the tallest height of the three,
which is allies height.
Is that right?
That correct.
All right,
so that's a pretty general idea and thanks.
Thanks guys.
We'll come back to in a second.
All right.
All right,
and let's think about this somewhere else.
I think about the,
the batting average of a team.
All right?
It's got the team batting average in baseball.
I just think that's used the Yankees for example,
we know that the team average,
the average batting average of the Yankees,
I don't know what it isn't.
I didn't look it up this morning,
but I know it lies somewhere between the player who has the highest batting
average,
which I'm guessing is Geeta,
I'm guessing,
uh,
and uh,
the lowest and the person on the team has the lowest batting average who's
probably one of the pictures you played who bad it a few times.
One of those into league games.
All right.
It'd be better if I'd used the mets,
but I,
I feel I should take pity on mets fans this week and not mention them.
All right.
All right,
so this is a very simple idea.
It's deceptively simple.
It says average is weighted averages lie between the highest thing over which
are averaging and the lowest thing over which are averaging.
All right?
Everyone okay with that idea?
All right.
Now this very simple idea is going to have an enormous consequence and here's
the enormous consequence,
right?
Simple idea,
big consequence.
So there's going to be a lesson that follows from this incredibly simple idea
and this is the lesson is a mixed,
a mixed strategy.
If a mixed strategy is a best response [inaudible] she is the best thing you can
be doing.
Then
each of the pure strategies
you should have the pure strategies in the mix.
I'm being a little bit loose tear,
but I mean assign positive policy in the mix for those people who are nerdy
enough to worry about it.
Each of the pure strategy is in the mix,
must
themselves
be best responses.
So in particular
in particular,
each must yield
the same expected payoff.
All right,
so here's a big conclusion that follows from that incredibly simple idea about
averages lying between the highest one in the lowest one and it's draw samples
from that lesson to this big conclusion,
right?
What does the conclusion,
the conclusion is if it,
if it makes strategy is the best response.
If it's the best thing I can do is to play,
I'm it strategy,
then each of the pure strategies which I'm playing in,
that makes one,
am I signing positive problems?
He too did that mix must themselves be best responses.
All right.
In particular each of them,
therefore Mr yield the same expected payoff.
So let's go back to our example.
It's gonna Kinda,
I'm sorry guys.
Can I steal my three TA's again?
I suppose the game,
I suppose the thing I'm involved in,
I should have made this easier before it would come down a little bit.
I'll stand above here.
Yeah,
this is good.
It's good.
Okay.
So suppose the game I've been,
I'm involved in the payoff and the game is a game in which I have to choose the
tallest group of my tas,
right?
So my payoff is going to be the average height of whichever subgroup of my TA's
I pick.
All right?
And these are my three choices.
So if I pick more than one of them,
right?
I think I'm going to get a weighted average that that's a mixed strategy.
All right?
My aim here is to maximize the height of whatever subgroup I pick.
So in this game,
here's my three choices.
He's my threes pure strategies,
my three pillar structures,
Myrto,
ally or Jake.
All right?
There's my,
there's my three PR strategies and my mixed dry could mix these two.
I could mix these two.
I can mix all three.
All right?
But remember,
my payoff here is to get the group the average as high as I can.
So how am I going to get the average as high as I can?
I'm I to average as high as I can.
He said cheating.
Yeah,
they get the average is high as I can.
I'm going to kick out Moroto for start.
All right.
Sorry.
So he was all right because motors just motors just bringing down the average,
is that right?
All right.
Average height,
I should say.
All right.
There's nothing,
right,
right.
And actually,
all right.
And I think I'm going to kick out Jake as well.
I think can hit people over the writing a portico kickout Jake as well,
because that way I just have ally,
right?
So if it was the case,
I was picking both of them,
it would have to be,
they were equally tall.
Right.
But since,
since they're not equal at all,
I should just pick them to the best one.
Right.
Let's go back to my Yankees example.
If I want to pick a sub team of the Yankees,
I'm gonna have to pick any number of people to have the highest average batting
average in that sub team.
The way to do it is to find the Yankee.
You has the highest batting average,
and just pick him.
All right.
Let's do one more example.
Let me use the front row of students here.
All right,
so here's my,
can I get this front row of students to stand up a second?
All right,
so this,
this,
this part of the row.
All right.
And suppose my aim in life is to construct the highest average GPA.
I'm not gonna embarrass these guys and ask them what their Ghg PA's are.
All right?
So,
so,
so my,
my aim in life here is to pick some subgroup of these.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight students such that the average of the average GPA,
yet that subgroup is as high as I can make it.
All right?
So what would I do here?
So this being Yale,
I'll just find the people who have the 4.0 GPA is and just pick them.
It's not right.
All right?
You might think,
well,
why not include somebody who has a 3.9 GPA?
That's pretty good.
So why nots?
Because if there's anybody in this group who has a 4.0 GPA,
I do better just to pick that person.
The 3.9 person would just be pulling down the average.
And I suppose there's nobody with a four o GPA and it's the case that three of
these guys,
three of these people,
let's say the three people have a 3.9 GPA,
right?
So these three,
half,
3.9 GPA,
imagine that.
And these other people,
they've got horrible grades like B plus somewhere.
Alright.
So these are our future law school students.
And these are the people who are,
who knows what they're going end up doing being president probably.
Alright.
So to the constructor,
the group with the highest average GPA,
what am I going to do?
Well first I'll throw out all these guys with low GPA so they can all sit down.
I look at these last three and these last three.
If they're all in the group,
they better all have the same GPA,
right?
Why not?
If,
if,
if I'm trying to maximize the average of my group,
if any of them had a lower GPA,
I should kick them out.
And if one of them has a higher GPA than the other two,
I should kick out both the other two.
So I'm including all three of them in my constructing of the average.
All of them must have the same GPA,
which I'm going to assume it's 3.9 to assume you can still make it into,
you'll enter law school.
All right,
everyone understand that?
Yup.
Okay,
thanks.
Thanks guys.
All right.
All right,
so that's,
that's the,
uh,
that's the way I want to think about this.
All right,
so the idea here is if I'm using a mixed strategy as a best response,
right?
It must be the case that everything on which I'm mixing is it self best and the
can,
the reason is if it wasn't kick out the thing that isn't best and my average
will go up.
All right.
So that leads us to the next idea.
But before I do,
just for formality,
let me add a definition.
The definition is this,
a mixed
strategy profile and I'm going to do,
now I'm going to define Nash equilibrium again.
That's what we have it on a note somewhere.
So a mixed strategy profile to be a hyphen there.
P One star p two star all the way up to p n star is a mixed strategy.
Nash equilibrium.
If
for each player I,
so for each eye we're going to be here for each player I,
let's play it I
that players mixed strategy.
Pi Star is a best response for player I
to the strategies.
Everyone else is picking p minus I star.
So I'm exploiting our buy now.
Well developed notation for play a strategist.
Let me get some more short.
All
right,
so this definition of Nash equilibrium,
it's exactly the same as the definition of Nash Equilibrium.
We've been using now for several weeks except everywhere,
right?
Where before we saw a pure strategy I've ripped,
which was an ass,
I have replaced it with a p,
right?
It's the same definition except I'm using mixed strategies instead of pure
strategies,
but an implication of an implication of our lesson is what?
It's that if p I star is part of a national equilibrium.
So if pis thought is the best response to Pete to whatever else is doing p minus
ice bar,
then each of the pure strategies involved in Pii star must itself be a best
response.
All right,
so an implication of the lesson is
the lesson implies the following.
If
Pis star of a particular strategy is positive,
it's in other words I'm using this strategy in my mix,
then that strategy is also
a best response
to what everyone else is doing.
Right?
Okay.
So from a,
from a math point of view,
this is the big idea of the day,
this board,
okay.
And I,
and if you're having trouble reading this,
the back,
trust me,
I've written that up on the handout that will appear magic beyond the computer
at the end of class
and about at the moment you're staring at this and it's all a bit new and as
well as being new,
you are saying,
okay,
but so what?
Why do I care about this Steve?
Seemingly a mundane fact.
All right.
And the reason,
the reason we're going to turn out to care about this seemingly mundane fact is
that this fact is going to make it remarkably easy to find nash equilibrium.
All right?
This facts right?
This,
this,
this lesson,
this idea that if I'm applying a pure strategy is part of the mix,
it must itself be a best response.
That's going to be the trick we're going to use in finding mixed strategy,
nasty equilibria.
All right?
And the only way I can illustrate that to you is to do it.
So I'm gonna spend the rest of today,
uh,
just doing that.
I'm going to look at them.
I'm going to look at a game and we're going to go through this game.
We'll discuss it a little bit because it's a fun game and we're going to find
the mixed strategy equilibria of this game.
Okay?
We know we're going that just not me.
I want to make sure before I go on,
are people looking very sort of a deer in the headlamps?
That was a lot of formality to get to get through in a,
in a short bit of time.
So how,
how,
um,
they might want to ask a question at this point.
UK.
Okay to go on.
All right.
Just remember that the,
the conclusion here comes from this very simple idea.
The simple idea is the payoff to a weighted average must lie between the best
and worst thing involved in the average.
And therefore,
if I'm including things in there as part of the best response,
they must all be good.
That's the simple idea.
This is the dramatic conclusion.
All right,
so any way to prove this,
you don't know,
I need to prove you.
There's this is useful is to go ahead and do it.
We're not going to do is I'm going to clean these boards and I'm going to start
showing an example.
All right?
And again,
don't panic.
I think a lot of people at this part of the class have a tendency to panic
because it's a new idea and seems like a lot of math around.
None of it's really hard math.
It's all kind of arithmetic.
It's just this idea of not panicking.
All right,
so things don't play.
Want to look at?
Yeah,
it's going to be from tennis.
Yeah.
And I'm going to consider a game within a game played by two tennis players and
let's call them a Venus and Serena Williams.
All right,
so Venus and Serena.
Oh William.
So a couple of years ago we used to use Venus and Serena Williams for this
example.
And then for awhile I worry that you wouldn't even remember who Venus and Serena
Williams where until we picked any two random Russians.
But now we're back.
It seems like we're back to picking Venus and Serena.
Alright,
so the game within the game is this,
suppose that they're playing and Serena is at the net,
right?
Is that the net?
And the ball is on venuses courts and Venus has reached the ball and Venus has
to decide whether to try to hit a passing shot,
a past Serena on the Serena's left or on Serena's rights.
And notice I'm going to exclude the possibility of throwing up a lobe for now.
All right.
Just make the get dust to make this manageable.
So basically the choice facing facing Venus is,
should she try to pass Serena just arenas left.
Which is the is backs,
backhand side order,
Serena's writes,
which is through Serena's forehand side.
Alright everyone,
people if I'm in love with tennis to understand what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
So we're going to assume this is Wimbledon.
Otherwise no one will be at the net to start with.
I guess this is it when we're done.
All right.
And let's try and put up some,
some payoffs here.
All right,
so these are going to be the payoffs.
I think that this example is originally due to,
uh,
to it.
Uh,
but it,
you know,
it doesn't,
it's not a big deal I think.
I think it's a,
I think this example is due to Dixit and skis.
Right?
So here's some numbers
and I'll explain the numbers in a minute.
So this is 50,
50,
80,
2090 10
and 2080.
Okay.
So what are these numbers?
So first of all,
let me just explain what the strategies are.
So I'm assuming the row player is,
be honest,
and the column player is Serena.
I'm assuming that if venuses Venus chooses l,
that means she attempts to pass Serena to Serena's left.
Alright,
well,
orange things from Trina's point of view.
And if she hits right,
that means she's attempting to pass Serena on Serena's right,
right?
And it's the Rena chooses owl.
That means she cheats slightly towards her left.
Not Cheats in the sense of breaking the rules,
but cheats in terms of where she's standing or leaning.
And if she chooses,
right,
that means he cheats slightly towards her,
right?
So this is cheating towards her backhand.
Now this is cheating towards her forehand,
assuming she's right handed,
which she in fact is okay.
And what do these numbers mean?
So let's start with the easy ones.
So,
uh,
if Venus chooses left and Serena chooses rights,
then Serena has guessed wrong.
Is that correct?
Right.
So many just guessed wrong,
in which case Venus winds the points 80% of the time and Serena winds it 20% of
the time,
right?
And conversely,
if Venus chooses right and Serena chooses left,
then again,
Serena has guessed wrong.
And this time Venus winds the point 90% of the time.
And Serena wind to the point 10% of the time.
All right.
And this should be a familiar idea by now,
but why is it the case that these nineties and eighties and not 100%?
Why is it the case that if Serena guesses wrong,
Venus doesn't win 100% of the time?
Anybody's approximate can show hands.
We get some mics at work.
Why isn't it 100% here?
Somebody's,
yeah,
uh,
um,
Patrick,
wait for the mic.
Sometimes she hits it right?
This isn't even a serve.
This is a passive job.
It would be the same as the same is true.
So some,
sometimes you're just,
you're gonna hit it past arena,
but the ball was going to say aloud.
All right,
so that happens 10% of the time here and 20% of the time here [inaudible] look
at the other two boxes.
If sir,
if Venus hits to Serena's left and Serena guesses left,
then we're going to assume that Serena's going to reach the ball and make a
volley.
But her volley only manages to go in,
get over the net and go in half the time.
So the payoffs are 50,
50,
half the time,
venous wounds.
The point and half the time Serino ends the point.
And conversely,
if Venus hits the bolters arenas,
right,
and Serena gets is correctly and chooses rights,
then we're in this box.
Once again,
Serena has guessed correctly and she's going to successfully reached the volley
and this time she gets it into 80% of the time.
So Venus Williams the point 20% of the time and Serena winds it 80% of the time.
Right?
So just to finish up the description of the game here,
notice that we're assuming that Serena is a little better at volleying,
uh,
to her,
right?
Then she is volleying to her left,
So this is her forehand volley,
and we're going to assume that that's stronger than her backhand volley.
Yeah.
All right.
And conversely,
we're assuming that Venus is passing shots is a little better when she shoots it
to Serena's left the,
when she shoots it just as arenas,
right?
This is her crosscourt passing shots and this is her down the line passing shot.
All right?
So none of that fine detail matters a great deal,
but just a good interested,
that's where the numbers come from.
Okay.
I'm not claiming this is true data.
By the way.
I made up these numbers.
Actually,
I think Dixit made up these numbers.
I forget why I got them from.
All right,
so,
okay,
everyone understand the game.
All right,
so now imagine either imagine you are Venus or Serena or imagine perhaps more,
more realistically that you've become Venus or Serena is coach.
Do you have any men have been members of the tennis team here?
No.
Well,
I imagine you've become their coach,
right?
So take this class and then you apply to replace their father as being that
coach.
All right.
That's a tough assignment,
do you think?
All right,
so an obvious question is,
you know,
here you are coaching Venus.
Before we move on,
you know this situation is going to arise and you weren't,
might want to coach Venus on.
What should she do here?
Should she try and pass Serena down the line or should she try and hit the cross
court of volume across CrossCorp passing shot?
All right.
And notice that this is a question of should I,
shouldn't,
should you Venus play to your strength,
which is the cross court passing shot or should you play to a Serenas,
uh,
Serenas weakness,
right?
Uh,
which is,
which would be to hit,
hit it to Serena's backhand,
right?
Playing to your strength is,
is to choose rights and playing to Sabrina's weakness is to choose left.
And conversely for Serena,
should you lean towards your strength,
which I guess is leaning to the right or should you,
uh,
lean towards a Venus is weakness,
which I guess is meaning,
right?
And when you look at coaching manuals on this stuff,
or you've listened to the terrible guys who commentate on tennis for Espn,
uh,
oh,
not getting in trouble again,
very nice guys who come to the tennis,
but ESPN,
they say just incredibly dumb things at this point,
right?
They say things like,
you should always play to your strengths and don't worry about the other
person's weakness.
Right?
I think it won't take much time today to figure out that to not great advice.
All right.
What can people can,
at least you,
this is a,
this is a difficult problem,
right?
There's not a,
it's not an immediately obvious problem.
That correct.
Is that correct?
One reason it's not immediately obvious is not only is no strategy dominated
here,
but there is no pure strategy.
Nash equilibrium in this game.
All right?
And this little sub game,
there is no pure strategy,
Nash equilibrium.
And there's that.
I did the qualifier.
Now previously I would just to said Nash equilibrium it.
But now that we have mixed strategist in the picture,
I'm going to talk about pure strategy,
national Culebra to be those that are only involving pure strategies.
Okay?
So why is the no pure strategy Nash Equilibrium?
Well,
let's have a look.
So if Venus,
if Serena thought that Venus was going to choose left,
then her best response,
not surprisingly,
is to lean left.
And if Serena thought that Venus was going to choose rights,
then her best response is to teach the rights.
All right,
so 50 is bigger than 20 and 80 is bigger than 10.
Right?
And conversely,
if Venus thought that Serena was cheating a bit to the left,
then her best response is to hit it to Serena's rights and if Venus thought
Serena was leaning to the right,
then Venus is best response is to hit it to Serena's laughed.
Okay,
so I think that's not at all surprising when you think about it,
not to talk to pricing.
You're going to get this little cycle like this,
but we can see immediately that these best responses never coincide.
So there is no pure strategy
equilibrium
that
up.
There's no pure strategy actually equilibrium.
All right,
so that leaves us a bit stuck,
accepted.
I guess it's,
I guess you know what the next question is going to be,
you know,
I shouldn't even in too much expense.
The next question is going to be okay,
there's no pure strategy,
Nash Equilibrium,
but we've just introduced a new idea,
which was what it was naturally pull Liberman mixed strategies.
Maybe there's going to be a mixed strategy national could have,
but in fact there is.
There is going to be one.
All right,
so all right.
Our exercise now is let's find,
let's find a
mixed strategy,
Nash equilibrium
before we find it.
That's just interpret what it's gonna mean.
A mixed strategy.
Nash equilibrium in this game is going to be a mix for Venus between hitting the
boulders,
arenas left and Serena's right and he makes for Serena between leaning left and
leaning writes such that each person's mix,
each person's randomization is a best to the other person's randomization.
Alright,
alright.
And since these players are sisters and I've played each other many,
many times,
not just in competition,
but probably in practice,
it seems like a reasonable idea that they might have arrived in playing each
other at that makes strategy.
Now shake,
whatever.
All right,
that's what we want to try and do.
Now how are we going to do that?
Okay,
so what we're gonna do is we're going to exploit,
we're going to exploit the trick that we have here.
The lesson here.
The lesson we have here says if players are playing a mixed strategy as part of
a Nash equilibrium,
each of the pure strategies involved in the mix,
each of their pure strategies must itself be a bass response.
We're going to use that idea.
All right,
so let's try and do that.
All right.
Tell me hoping that by doing this,
I'm going to illustrate to you immediately that this,
this idea is actually useful,
least useful if you end up coaching the Williams sisters.
All right,
so I want to keep this so you can still read it up and bring it down a bit.
Can people still read it?
Okay,
so what I want to do is I want to find a mixture first,
Serena and a mixture for Venus that our equilibrium.
All right,
and I could have just put it up there.
Let me bring it down again,
this was not too intelligent of me.
I actually want to bring in some notation.
So as before,
let's assume that v Serena's mix is it's used Q and one minus Q to be Serena's
mix and let's use P and one minus P two B business.
This mix.
Okay,
let's just establish that notation.
So here's the trick.
All right,
so this is the slightly magic bit of the class.
Okay,
so pay attention.
I'm about to pull a rabbit out of a hat.
Trick
to find.
What should I do first?
The find Serenas Nash equilibrium mix.
So that's Q one minus Q.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to look at Venus's payoffs just to find Serenas
Nash equilibrium makes.
The trick is to look at
Venus's
pay offs.
That's going to be my magic trick.
All right,
let's try and see why.
So let's look at Venus.
This payoffs,
penises,
payoffs,
uh,
against.
Okay,
cute,
right?
So three new is choosing Q one minus Q.
So what is what a Venus is payoffs?
So if she chooses,
if she chooses
left,
then pay off is 50 with probability Q.
And I'm going to use the pointer here and hope that the camera can see this too.
She gets 50 with probability Q
and she gets
a c with provosts,
one minus key.
Okay.
If she chooses right,
then she gets 90 with probability Q.
All right.
[inaudible] with problems the queue
and she gets 20
with provost,
even one minus Q.
Oh,
I meant to point to that 20 with Pelosi,
one minus key.
All right,
so what,
so what is this?
We're looking for a mixed strategy.
Nash equilibrium.
So in particular,
not only Serena is mixing,
but in this case what we're,
what we're claiming is Venus is mixing as well.
All right?
So if Venus is mixing as well,
that means that Venus is using the strategy left with some probability p and
using the strategy writes with some probability one minus B.
Since Venus sometimes chooses left and sometimes chooses rights
as her best response to queue,
does that best responses to Rena?
What must be true?
All of the payoff to left and the payoff to right.
Let's go through it again,
right?
So we're going to assume that Venus is mixing.
So sometimes you choose his left and sometimes she chooses,
right?
And she's going to be,
she's a Nash Equilibrium,
so she's choosing a best response.
So whatever that mix p woman as peers,
it's a best response.
Right.
Since,
since,
since she's,
she's,
since she's putting your best response of p and that that sometimes involves
choosing left sometimes involves Tuesday writes,
it must be the case that what it must be the case that both left itself and
writes itself are both themselves best response.
Right?
Right.
If she's mixing between them,
it must be that both choosing left or choosing reits are themselves best
response is if they weren't,
she should just drop them out of the mix.
That would raise her average payoff.
Right.
Just like we dropped out the short two yeas to get a high,
a high height and we dropped out the feeling Yale students to get a high GPA.
Sorry.
All right.
All right,
so if,
if if Venus,
if Venus is mixing
in this Nash Equilibrium,
then
the payoff
to left and turn right
must be equal.
They must both be best with both,
both left and right.
Must be a best response.
So in particular,
the expected payoffs must be the same.
Is that right?
Is that correct?
Okay.
So w what,
what does that allow me to do?
It allows me to put an equal sign in here.
It allows me to put an equal sign in here,
right?
The payer since laughter's the best response and right,
the best response is that booth best responses,
they must yield the same expected payoff.
Here's the expected payoff.
They must be the same.
And now I've got one equation and one on known,
and now I'm down to Algebra.
So let me do the Algebra I claim this expression is equal to that expression.
So simplifying a bit,
uh,
I'm going to get,
and you should watch,
make sure I don't get this wrong.
I'm going to get 40 cubes.
This implies 40 Q is equal to 61 minus Q.
So I took this 50 onto this side and this 20 onto that side.
So I have 40 Q equals 61 minus Q,
and that implies that Q is equal to 0.6.
All right,
so those last two steps,
we'll just Algebra.
All right.
So what was the trick here?
The trick was I found queue,
which is how Cirina is mixing by looking at Venus.
Is Payoffs knowing that Venus is mixing it and hence I can set Munis.
Is Payoffs uh,
equal to another?
All right.
Say it again.
I found the way in which Cirina is mixing by knowing that if Venus is mixing her
expected payoffs must be equal.
And I sold out for Serena's mix.
This is arenas mix.
Okay,
let's do it again.
Let's do it again
here.
I'm wishing I had another board and maybe I
don't want to lose those numbers entirely.
So I'm going to try and squeeze in a batch.
I know I can do,
let's get rid of this one entirely.
There we go.
Well Alex,
let's get rid of this one at tiny.
I can still see my numbers
and let's do the converse.
Let's do the trick again.
This time what I'm gonna do is I'm going to figure out how Venus is mixing.
I know how Serena's mixing now.
So now I'm going to work out how Venus is mixing
now to figure out how,
uh,
I would say it didn't have to figure out how Serena was mixing.
I used Venus is payoffs.
So to find out how Venus is mixing it,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to use Serena's payoffs.
Alright,
so
to find venuses
makes,
which is p one minus p.
Just be careful and it's her nash equilibrium.
Makes
use Serenas
payoffs.
Here we go.
Surf Serina if Serena chooses,
this is ss payoffs.
If Serena chooses l,
then her payoffs will be watched.
So,
and again,
what?
Just what?
I don't want to try to get this wrong and I'll point to the things to try and
help myself a bait.
So with probability p she'll get 50.
All right,
so 50 with problems,
EAP,
um,
with privacy,
one minus p she'll get 10.
All right?
And if she chooses to lean to the right to lean towards her forehand,
then with provosts he peed,
she'll get 20.
Okay.
And with probability one minus P,
she'll get 80.
Okay.
And we know that Serena is mixing.
We know that Serena is mixing.
So since Serena is mixing,
what must be true of these two payoffs?
Okay.
Oh,
it must be true of the to payoff the payoff to little owl and the payoff,
the little r.
What must be true about them since to Rena is using a mixture of these two
strategies in Nash Equilibrium.
It must be the case that both little Al is the best response and [inaudible]
response,
in which case the payoff must be someone tried it out equal.
Thank you.
They must be equal.
These must be equal.
He's supposed to be equal.
They must be equal.
Since Serena is indifferent between choosing left or right and hence his mixing
over them.
All right,
so again,
using the fact that they're equal reduces this to Algebra.
And again,
I'll probably get this wrong,
but let me try.
So I claim and state 20 away from here.
I've got 30 P equals 71 minus P.
I hope that's right.
That's what that looks right.
Again,
this is just Algebra at this point.
So I took 20 away from here in 10 away from there.
And this implies that p equals o into seven.
Alright,
so I claim I have now found the mixed strategy.
Now whatever hair it is,
the nash equilibrium is as follows.
Let's be careful.
This is venuses,
this is venuses
mix.
So Venus is mixing
0.7 0.3 0.7 on left and 0.3 on rights and Serena is mixing 0.6 0.4 all right,
so this is Venus is mix and this is Serena's mix.
Venus is is uh,
shooting to the left of center.
We've probably 2.7 and Serena is leaning that way with privacy 0.6
all right,
so we were able to find this nash equilibrium by using the trick before.
And let's just reinforce this a little bit by talking about it.
So I suppose it with a case,
suppose it with a case that Serina instead of leaning to the left 0.6 of the
time lend to the left more than 0.6 at the time.
And I suppose your Venus is coach,
your Venus is coach.
And suppose you know that Serena leans to the left more than 0.6 of the time,
what would you advise beingness to do?
All right,
let me try it again.
So suppose your Venus is coach,
and suppose you've observed the fact that Serena leans to the left more than 0.6
at a time,
what would you advise me as to do?
Yeah,
still the right thing.
Yeah.
So it out yet as to the right pass to the right.
Exactly.
So if Serena,
she's to the left more than 0.6 of the time,
then Venus is best response is always to shoot to the right,
always to shoot to the right.
That maximizes her chance of winning,
winning the point.
And conversely,
if Serena leans to the left,
left less than 0.6 at the time,
if Serena leans to the left less than 0.6 at the time,
then Venus should do was
shoot to the left all the time.
All right,
so Serena,
if Serena doesn't choose exactly this mix,
it's really didn't choose exactly this mix,
then Venus is best response is actually a pure strategy,
right?
Say it again.
If Serena lean to the left to Austin more than 0.6,
then Venus would just go,
right.
And if Serena leans to the left to nipple,
then Venus should always go left.
Right?
And we can do exactly the same the other way round if Venus shoots to the right.
So it does how cross the hand passing shots more than 0.7 at the time.
And your Serena's coach,
what did you tell Sabrina to do?
Yeah,
go that way all the time.
Go that way all the time.
All right.
So if Venus is hitting it to Serena's left more than 0.7 at the time,
so we need to just always go to her left.
And if Venus is hitting to the,
uh,
to the left,
less than 0.7 at the time.
So to the right,
more than 0.3 of the time then.
So we should always go to the right,
right?
So that's,
that's how this kind of comes back into the sort of coaching manuals and you're
like,
okay,
so how,
how am I doing so far?
People?
Have I lost everyone yet or are people still with me?
How many of you play tennis ever?
All right,
so all know tennis is going to dramatically improve after today,
right?
All right.
Okay,
so now let's make life more interesting.
Let's go back to the stars.
We figured out this isn't equilibrium.
This is how Venus and Serena,
Venus and Serena know each other perfectly well.
They know that they mixed this way.
They're going to best respond to it.
He's going to where they at,
where they end up.
But in the meantime,
Serina hires a new coach and Serena's new coach is just very,
very good at teaching the Serena how to play at the net and in particular how to
hit the backhand volley.
Alright,
so Serena's new,
let's say it's Tony Roche or somebody.
It's just a brilliant coach and Tony Roche is able to improve Serenas backhand
volley and that changes this,
these payoffs.
So I usually use it,
we write the whole Matrix,
but I'm going to cheat.
All right?
So the new game is exactly the same as it was everywhere else except for now.
When Serena gets to the backhand volley,
she gets it in 70% of the time.
All right,
so they used to be 50,
50 in that box and now it's 30,
70.
All right,
so the game has changed because Serena has got better.
I hit him backhand volley is,
and we want to figure out how is this going to effect play at Wimbledon?
All right.
How's this going to affect play at Wimbledon?
No,
it doesn't take much to check that there is still no pure strategy,
Nash equilibrium.
It's still the case.
In fact,
even more so that Serena's best response to a venous choosing left is to lean to
the left.
All right?
So it's still the case that the best response is do not go inside.
There is still no pure strategy,
whatever.
All right,
what we're going to do,
of course it's going to find a mixed strategy equilibrium.
But before we do so let's think about this intuitively,
but see if we can intuit announce that.
All right.
I'm guessing we can't,
but let's see if we get intuition.
The old set.
All right.
So Serena has improved her backhand,
Lena,
how backhand volley and hence,
uh,
when she reached it,
she gets it in more often.
All right.
So one affects you might think is what we might want to call a direct effect.
And there's two effects,
yet
there are two effects.
One of these I'm going to call the direct effect.
And by effect,
I mean in particular an effect on how Serena should play the game.
All right?
So since Serena has improved her backhand volley,
when she reaches that Bali,
she gets it in more often.
So one might say,
in that case,
you'll Salinas coach.
In that case,
you should lean to the left more often than you did before,
right?
Because at least when you get that backhand volley,
you're going to get it in more often.
So the director facts says Serena
should lean left more.
In other words,
he should go up.
Is that right?
So Serena's now better at playing this backhand volley so she might as well
favorite a bit more.
Uh,
and hemp Q will go up.
So I asked the director facts,
but of course there's a box coming.
What's the box again?
That's a see my tennis players.
Yeah.
Raise,
raise your hands or your place tenants or something.
Suddenly nobody plays 10 it's going to raise it.
All right.
Okay.
What's the box here?
We think Serena's backhand improved so she might be tempted to play towards her
back end a bit more often.
What's the bus?
Just the part here.
So I cleaned the butters.
This you told me if I'm wrong,
the bus is that Venus?
She's a sister after.
All right.
So Venus knows that Serena's backhand has improved,
so Venus is going to hit it.
Just arenas left less often than before.
Is that right?
Since Serena's backhand is improved,
Venus is going to hit it to three in his backhand less often than before.
And that might make Serena less inclined to cheat towards her backhand because
the ball is coming that way less often.
All right,
so this is a indirect or a strategic effect.
The strategic effects,
the strategic effects is Venus hits owl less often.
So Serina
should reduce the number of times that she leans to the left because the ball's
coming in that way a few fewer times.
Now notice that these two effects going opposite directions.
That right?
All right.
One of them tends to argue that Q would go up.
That's the director of facts.
And the other one is more subtle.
It says,
we now think about not just how my players improved,
but also how the other person's going to respond to.
It's a knowing that my players improves as the more subtle effects.
And that's going to push queue down.
That's gonna make it less lately.
Uh,
argue against leaning to the left.
All right,
so imagine you're going to be Serena's coach.
Which of these effects do you think is going to want to have a poll?
Which of these effects you think's gonna win the direct effects or the indirect
rate?
The direct effect of the strategic effects.
Who thinks?
Who is,
who thinks the direct effect?
Who thinks?
Who would advise Serena to play to her strength a bit more and lean left a bit
more?
Who thinks the director facts?
Raise your hands.
That type of pole
and who thinks the indirect effect?
The effect of Serena head.
It gets that way less often.
It's going to win.
And who's abstaining?
And basically refusing to be a coach.
Okay,
great number of you.
All right.
All right,
well we're going to find out.
We're going to find out.
Okay.
Without,
by resolving
for the Nash Equilibrium
we're going to do is redo the calculation we did before starting
with Serena.
So to find Serena's mix to find Serena's new equilibrium mix.
What do we have to do,
right?
Wait,
wait.
The question is in equilibrium is through either going to going to lean to the
left more so cute is going to go.
Got up or less accustom to go down.
So I need to find out what is Serena's new equilibrium mix.
What's the new queue?
How do I go about finding Serena's equilibrium queue?
What's the trick here?
Shout it out.
One,
two,
three.
What's the
use VTCs payoffs,
right?
To find,
to find,
okay.
To find the new Hugh
for Serena use.
Venuses
payoffs I.
Let's do that.
So from Venus,
his point of view,
if she chooses left,
then her pay offs are now,
and again I should use the pointer
thirsty with problems.
The Queue,
this is the new Q and Athe with problems you one minus Q
thirsty but property Q plus 81 minus Q.
Again,
this is the new Q.
I should really give it actually called Q prime or something.
What I work
and if she chooses rights
then her pay off is what
it's going to be.
90 with provosts,
Dq and 20 with property.
One minus Q
90 with probably the Q and 20 was privacy one minus Q.
And what do we know about these two pay offs?
If Venus is mixing an equilibrium and we know she's mixing any Gremlins,
which as we saw there was no pure strategy color room.
So what do we know about these two payoffs?
Since Venus is using both the strategies and equilibrium,
they must be the same as,
and she's using both of these strategies.
These strategies must be equally good.
They must both be best responses.
So these two payoffs are equal since they're equal.
All I have to do is solve out for cues.
So let's do it.
So I'm going to guess 90 minus 30 is 60 queue is equal to 80 minus 20 which is
61 minus Q.
So Q equals
0.5
all right.
So then if I,
if I,
if I did the Algebra you quickpay,
just trust me,
I think.
I think I got it right.
Right from here on it.
And it was just an Algebra.
All right,
so what am I found out?
Did Q go apple go down?
What?
It used to be Q used to be 1.6 and now it's 0.5 let me ask what I think is an
easy question.
Did it go up or down?
It went down.
It went down,
right then it went down,
right?
Queue went down,
the equilibrium queue went down.
All right,
so which affects turned out to be bigger?
The direct effects of playing more to your strength or the indirect effect I've
taken to account that your opponent is going to play less often to your springs,
which affect turned out to be the bigger effect.
The indirect,
right?
The strategic effects.
Of course,
I rigged it.
I want the strategic be bigger because this is a course about strategy,
right?
All right.
All right,
but the strategic effects actually want to hear,
okay.
The streets are strategic.
In fact,
the indirect effect is bigger.
All right.
That's good news for me because it says the slightly dumb coach who didn't
bother to take game theory would have stopped at this director of facts and they
did told Serena to go the wrong way,
but the smart coach who takes my class and therefore somehow contributes to my
salary and an extraordinary indirect way gets it.
Right.
All right.
The strategic bigger now we can also solve out for Venus is new mix,
but I am.
I will do it in a second,
but before I do it,
let me just point out that we actually can,
we really can now intuit Venus is a effect.
Maybe not the exact numbers,
but we can intuit it.
I claim I claim if we think this through carefully,
we know whether Venus is shooting more to the left when she was before or more
or less to the left than she was before.
All right?
Notice that in the new equilibrium,
Cirina is going less often to her left even though she's better at hitting the
backhand is better at hitting the ball when she gets back.
So since Serena is leaning left less often,
what must be true about Venus and this new equilibrium?
It must be the case that Venus is hitting the ball to the left last offer.
All right,
that makes that,
that,
that makes sense.
We kind of,
we have enough information already on the board.
Tell us that.
Nevertheless,
let's do the math.
Let's do the math.
So,
um
hmm.
All right,
let's go and retrieve a board.
Just the completeness.
Let's figure out exactly what Venus does do.
All right,
so to figure out what Venus is going to do,
what's our trick?
I want to figure out how this is going to mix.
I'm going to find out Venus is new.
P,
how do I out Venus is new equilibrium mix.
I look at Serena's payoffs.
Alright,
so if Serina chooses left,
her pay off is,
and I'll read off quickly this time is 70 p plus s hen one minus p.
And if Serena chooses,
writes,
her pay off is 20 p plus 81 minus p.
And I'm just praying that the ta is going to catch me if I make a mistake here.
And I know these have to be equal because I know that in fact Venus is mixing,
uh,
sorry.
I know that Serena is mixing.
All right,
so I know these must be equal.
So since they're equal,
I can solve a out and hope that I've got this right.
So I've got 50 p equals 71 minus P,
so p is equal to a seven 12th so again,
that's just Algebra.
I rushed in Tibet,
it's just Algebra.
Same idea,
just Algebra.
So seven 12th is indeed smaller than what it used to be because it used to be a
seven tenths.
All right?
So that confirms our result.
Okay.
So the strategic effect dominated Venus shot,
does arenas backhand the less often and as a consequence so much,
so much.
It's so that's Terina actually found it worthwhile going more to the right than
she used to before.
All right.
Now let's just talk this through one more time.
This was a comparative statics exercise.
We looked at a game,
we found an equilibrium,
we change something fundamental about the game and we looked again to look at
the new equilibrium that's called comparative statics.
And let's talk through the intuition before we made any changes.
Venus was indifference right before maybe it changes.
Venus was indifferent,
she was indifferent between shooting to the left and shooting to the rice,
then we improved Cirina his ability to hit the volatile her left or even
improved her backhand volley.
If we had not changed the way Serina played,
if we'd not changed the way arena played,
then what would Venus have done?
Just oppose.
In fact,
Serena's Q had not changed.
If Serena Q had not changed Roman,
that Venus was indifferent before,
how would Venus or changed her play?
[inaudible].
So if we started from the old cue and then we improve Serena's ability to pay
the backhand belt volley.
And if Q didn't change,
what would Venus had done?
She never ever shopped with afternoon more.
She'd only have shot to the right.
Only a shock to the rights,
which can't possibly be in equilibrium.
So something about Serena's play has to bring Venus back into equilibrium and
mess.
It brings Venus back into being indifference.
And what was it?
It was Serina,
uh,
moving,
to the,
to the left less often and moving to the,
to the right more often.
All right.
Say again.
If we didn't change cue,
Venus would only go to the rights.
So we need to reduce queue,
have Serina go to the right to bring Venus back into equilibrium.
Matt.
And conversely,
if Venus hadn't changed her behavior,
if Venus had gone on shooting exactly the same as she was p and one minus p s
before then,
Serena would have only gone to the left.
And that can't be an equilibrium.
So it must be something about Venus is play brings Serena back into equilibrium.
And what is it?
It's that Venus start shooting to the rights more often.
All right,
so does two reminders to,
are you leave two reminders?
Wait,
wait,
wait.
First.
In about five minutes' time,
a handout will magically appear on the web websites that goes through these
arguments.
Again,
all of them in two other games.
So you can have a look at the handout.
Second thing,
a problem sites has already appeared by magic on that website that gives you
lots of examples like this to work on.
All right.
Play tennis over the weekend for practice and we'll see you on Monday.